[Music]
no no no oh
[Music]
um
what is this
i'm shorter than kevin hart
[Music]
what the i'm a cartoon
is this where the game is gonna happen
[Music]
where is everybody
hello
hello
hello
hello
rabbit season
what the [ __ ]
leave me alone
[Applause]
up doc
duck season
bucks bunny
bugs
i can't believe
bring it in man
listen i need your help hmm er you
missed your cue
whoa
rabbit season all right yeah now say i'm
hunting rabbits and try to chase me
bugs wait
come back
[Music]
oh
i should have seen that coming
[Music]
true
see have i seen you somewhere
hey you're the famous basketball guy
come on aren't you lebron james
pugs bunny knows who i am
oh of course i may live in a hole in the
ground but we still get tnt oh my god is
that a yep some of your ears
[Music]
why would you do that
[Music]
i'm a tune doc i can survive anything
i'm
not no no no no no no no
out
i do not understand this world
um
[Music]
how long have you been alone here alone
you're never alone when you got friends
like mine doc ain't that right porky uh
that's just a pile of pumpkins
porky did you hear what he just called
you
[Music]
so what brings you to tonwa doc
corn meniscus
midlife crisis
run out of teams to play for
[Music]
uh all i know is a computer dude
kidnapped my son and i have to play
basketball to get him back his name is
al g rhythm did you say
algae riddim
yeah that's a guy rhythm rhythm whatever
that nefarious nimrod nick's my nearest
and dearest from tune wild he kicked
them out well not exactly
he butted them up saying they were
wasting their time that there was much
more to see in a soybear voice than old
two world
well i wish them all the best in their
new endeavors
oh man sorry bugs that's terrible
family's everything
yep
family
well bugs bunny i need to assemble an
elite team of a-plus ball players to
help crush this algae god and i need to
do it before
that game clock runs down
oh hold up doc so you want me you're
talking cartoon bunny to play with you
an nba superstar in a high-stakes
basketball game
sounds awfully familiar who are you
talking to but yeah that actually sums
it up well hmm
i think i know a way that can help to
both of us
[Music]
i declare this land for planet
[Music]
[Music]
not so fast furry creature
excuse me
marvin the martian
for real
i claim this planet in the name of mars
my goodness my mistake partner i thought
this land was in the clear
well we'll just get back on our ship and
out of your way oh it's quite all right
everyone makes mistakes come on let's
boogie what you're selling this [ __ ] i
didn't agree to this my shift
[Music]
take this rabbit
would you rather hang back with a cranky
martian in his space mud just watch out
for the just watch out for the ah i just
said watch out for you
you have made me very angry
very angry indeed
you